Who's calling today from nine four, nine maybe
third time.
Is The charm here?
Yes.
Hey David, this is Patrick.
I'm calling from Orange County, California.
Hey Patrick, what's up?
Um, first of all, I really love your show.
I listen every other day.
Thank you, ma'am.
I just wanted to get a quick question from,
yeah.
Um, how do you feel about the legalization
or decriminalization of like silicide mushrooms,
magic mushrooms?
Yeah.
I know that Denver, Denver does dealing with
that.
They had actually what happened with the vote
in Denver.
Uh, to be honest, I don't know.
I think it was just yesterday, so I'd have
to check off.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh, I think, I mean, certainly the decriminalization.
Absolutely.
Yes.
And on legalization I might even lean towards
yes.
As well.
On, on psilocybin.
How far do you go with like, um, narcotics
in general, do you think?
I have a question about the legal, the, the
recreational legalization of cocaine.
Like I'm, I'm just unsure about that.
I'm unsure about recreational heroin.
I've seen very good arguments that those should
be decriminalized but not legalized recreationally.
So I did a segment about it where I said it,
I'm not taking like a moralistic position.
It's just not as clear to me, like with cannabis
recreationally legal.
Absolutely.
Silicide been recreationally legal, probably
cocaine, heroin, I'm just unsure.
Yeah.
It's kind of a, I wouldn't say slippery slope,
but it's how do you judge what the society
will turn into if you legalize that type of,
that's one component of that that we could
consider.
Sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
Hey, I really appreciate you answering my
call.
All right, very good.
Great to hear from you.
Uh, that's all the time I have for today.
Sorry to everybody I didn't get to, but we
will take calls again.
Quick break audience questions coming up next.